[Music]
welcome to the program we have maybe the
best show we've ever done and quite
possibly not
that guy was down with what are you
waving at me sir
a bobble hair doll pass that down
somebody pass it down
okay that's this is just insulting
i love this but what's with my mouth
here what's with my get in tight on that
why why am i doing
[Applause]
thank you very much here take that
that's for me
thank you everyone
everyone please pass your handmade gifts
forward
but only if they're in your likeness
yeah yeah yeah you have other ones uh
welcome to the show what a great crowd
tonight we're gonna have a good time and
uh who's excited about the super bowl
you ready to go
how have you heard this a uh
in an interview yesterday madonna said
she's nervous about performing at the
super bowl
madonna's nervous yeah
she's also not happy that they're
calling it the scary cougar halftime
show
that's weird
i just love the name
who are you for do you care who wins oh
i'm for madonna
and you'll win all right
how have you heard this supermodel
giselle bundchen wants people to yeah
wow that's all apparently i have to say
uh
no supermodel giselle bunchen wants
people to pray for her husband tom brady
to win the super bowl
yeah
yeah in response god said you know what
i think i've done enough for tom brady
i think
you think about it
if only he had a better life
she got cursed with that face and that
wife she did get an answer though which
supermodels when they talk to god they
get answers that's true
but the best republican presidential
race has moved on to nevada did you know
that after losing in florida newt
gingrich is now campaigning very hard in
las vegas
newt is in las vegas
gingrich said he loves las vegas because
it has two of his favorite things
buffets and wedding chapels
make a bobblehead of that joke uh
rapper kanan is upset because mitt
romney used his rap song during romney's
victory speech in florida
yeah and he's mad about it yeah canon
said that's the last time i write a song
called miso mormon
and he likes it too
they've chosen a new voice to play dora
the explorer
yeah
and i just want to say thank you for the
opportunity
kids i will not let you down
vamanos
we did it backpack
look
i'm laughing too hard at that
i don't know what's going on over here
i don't know if you heard this they're
coming out with a new updated version of
the ancient sex manual the kama sutra
yeah i think
i think they may have made it too modern
because the first position it describes
is the dougie
i don't get that joke at all
[Applause]
half an hour before the show i'm trying
that out on interns yeah yeah yeah no no
that should be okay
this doggy what is this dougie you speak
of
can we get a young person in here to
find out if that's funny
i'm 77 years old
and proud of it
katy perry is in the news it's being
reported that katy perry katy perry may
be releasing a 3d concert movie
3d concert movie yeah and instead of 3d
glasses you'll get protective goggles
don't know
now he's not liking it it's just the
hair when the hair moves that little